bonsoir
alors moi je suis venu vous prévenir que
la science est en train de rattraper la
fiction parce que en ce moment on est en
train de s'équiper des moyens
d'observation qui vont permettre aux
gens de notre génération de détecter de
voir et de caractériser les planètes
habitables et potentiellement habité qui
peuplent notre galaxie
cette question de la pluralité des
mondes
c'est quelque chose qui nous tarabustent
depuis assez longtemps c'est quelque
chose qu'on retrouve bien avant par
exemple le début de la première trilogie
star wars c'est quelque chose qu'on
retrouve par exemple dans les écrits qui
datent du ivème siècle avant notre ère
incertain epicure qui écrivait un de ses
collègues
hérodote les piqûres été fan des des
théories atomiste de démocrite et il se
disait mon lisant démocrite qu' il y
avait finalement tellement d'atom dans
l'univers qui avait au prix a priori
aucune raison pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
la même façon qu'ils avaient une
infinité de l'atome une infinité de
mondes sur lequel on pouvait imaginer
tout un tas de choses alors à l'époque
j'imagine que si hérodote avait eu un
téléphone portable il y aurait vite
envoyé un texto en dix ans l ol ou
quelque chose comme ça mais les moeurs
était un petit peu différente
c'est intéressant de penser à ce que les
anciens pouvait avoir en tête en
particulier dans leur relation qui
pouvait avoir au ciel
on a entendu tout à l'heure finalement
des anciens d'aujourd'hui qu'une
certaine façon qui ont par rapport à
nouer une relation très différentes ce
qui les différencie complètement par
rapport au ciel c'est qu'ils vivaient
principalement en majoritairement dans
un univers qui n'était pas dominé par la
lumière artificielle et donc de ce fait
ils avaient une expérience beaucoup plus
personnel est beaucoup plus direct de ce
qu'est vraiment le ciel alors maintenant
on peut trouver que certaines de leurs
idées étaient un petit peu farfelue
n'empêche que pour eux les mythes qu'ils
ont créée avec du sang s'est reflétée de
certaines réalités dont il faisait
l'expérience
tous les jours notre relation aussi à
l'eau aujourd'hui est très très
différentes et ressemble un peu plus à
ça ou on se focalise presque plus sur
l'écran qui nous explique ce qu'on est
censé voir si on faisait vraiment
attention à ce qu'on regarde et on en
oublie un petit peu la réalité qui est à
derrière les écrans et ça c'est vrai
même dans certains cas pour beaucoup des
astronomes professionnels qui a qui ont
jamais vraiment pris le temps non plus à
de se poser dehors d'attendre que votre
oeil s'habitue progressivement
l'obscurité ce qui va vous prendre au
moins un bon quart d'heure pour vraiment
commencer à être capable de voir les
choses et puis la seule coûte vous
laisser vous perdra dans le nombre dans
la quantité des choses qui à avoir parce
que d'un seul coup si vous y passez un
peu plus que 5 minutes vous allez vous
rendre compte que c'est pas des bêtises
qu'on vous a dit que la terre c'est
vraiment un petit vaisseau spatial qui
se promène dans l'univers et à qui nous
permet de voir tout ça alors des étoiles
vous vous dit qu'on irait beaucoup plus
que ce que vous pensiez et dans celle
qui circule là il y en a une en
particulier dont je voudrais parler
maintenant une étoile dans la
constellation de pégase la 51e par de
brillance donc on l'appelait 51 pegasi
elle est pas particulièrement bruyante a
du coup mais il a quelque chose de
particulier cette étoile est pour elle
en fait il ya deux jours on célébrait un
anniversaire qu'on juge très important
c'était le 20e anniversaire de la
découverte d'une planète en orbite
autour de cette étoile et c'était la
première
avant ça on avait vécu en gros 400 en
astronomie moderne depuis l'invention du
télescope par galilée où on était
conscients de l'existence d'un seul
système planétaire le nôtre et on avait
peint au fur et à mesure compris qu'il y
avait les petites planètes rocheuses qui
était plus ou moins près du soleil dont
la nôtre et puis un peu plus loin les
planètes géantes jupiter saturne uranus
neptune et maintenant on sait que encore
plus loin il ya d'autres petits trucs
mais on avait construit cette image
mentale de systèmes solaires idéal et
puis finalement on s'imaginer que le
premier truc qu'on retrouve rennes
ressemblerait forcément à ça 51 pegasi b
a été une grosse surprise est assez
difficile à digérer au début parce qu'on
a découvert un système autour duquel il
y avait une étoile une planète de la
taille de jupiter qui était tellement
près de son étoile qu'elle en faisait le
tour en quatre jours et demi alors que
la planète la plus proche dans notre
système solaire c'est mercury l'état lui
prend presque trois mois de faire le
tour donc c'était quelque chose a priori
auquel on croyait pas mais bon deux
astronomes suisse qui observaient depuis
le sud de la france avec un télescope de
2 mètres avec un instrument qu'ils
avaient construit qui s'appelait elodie
enregistré ces espèces de variations
périodiques dans leur signal et
l'amplitude de ce signal là et est
indicative de la masse de la planète
qu'ils observaient et la période
évidemment été relié à la période orbite
de cette planète
vingt ans plus tard aujourd'hui j'ai
encore vérifié tout à l'heure avant de
démarrer on en est à 1969 planète dont
on a confirmé l'existence autour
d'autres étoiles que notre soleil alors
danser 1969 il y en a il y en a presque
500 qui sont des systèmes multiples où
il ya plein de planètes autour de tout
ça et donc on est obligé d'utiliser les
sites internet parce que les gens
publient dans tous les sens et donc il
ya des gens qui s'amusent à garder les
compteurs en permanence à jour et si
vous prenez ne serait-ce que nos plus
proches voisines dans les sens plus
proche des années lumière ce qui est
vraiment vraiment pas très loin quand on
pense aux distances astronomiques est
bon on trouve plusieurs un peu plus
d'une centaine d'objets qu'on a deux
noms dont on a déjà découvert
l'existence et ça vous montre qu'on a
des voisins dans toutes les directions
dans le ciel jusque là toutes ces
détections et et indirects on n'a jamais
été on a encore très rarement été
capable de voir les planètes en question
les deux méthodes qui marche le plus
sont les méthodes dites de vitesses
radiales qui était celle de 51 pegasi ou
en fait on détecte l'effet dynamique
planète à autour d'une étoile savez on
dit tout le temps que les et les
planètes tournent autour des étoiles
c'est pas exactement vrai en fait les
deux tourne l'un autour de l'autre il ya
juste que dans notre cas le soleil très
très massif et donc ils bougent pas
beaucoup mais ils bougent d'un petit peu
et ce mouvement là on est capable de
détecter de le détecter sur plein des
toiles et l'amplitude du mouvement en
gros 20 plus la planète et massive de
plus elle est proche et plus ça va faire
le gigoter notre étoile
une autre technique qui est très
chouette c'est comparable à ce qui s'est
passé encore il ya quelques années mais
quand venus est passé 1 devant notre
soleil c'est une photo que j'ai prise en
fait à l'époque en 2012 et donc on
arrive à voir le observer le passage de
planète devant leur étoile qui vont
créer une petite ombre et comme on suit
avec nos instruments la luminosité de
ces étoiles là eh ben on va être capable
en regardant la profondeur à de l'ombre
que sacré de connaître la taille de
cette planète là alors maintenant avec
la vitesse radiale on connaît les masses
avec le transit où on connaît la taille
d'un seul coup on est capable de faire
un petit peu de physique puis de
commencer à réfléchir à savoir
mais qu'est ce que à quoi ça ressemble à
la surface de cet objet là on est
capable de dire qu'est ce que ça va être
comme gravité quelle va être la densité
est ce qu'on va être capable d'avoir une
planète rocheuse ou pas et ont du coup
pour commencer à réfléchir à savoir mais
est-ce que s'est plaint d'être là sont
potentiellement habitables ou pas alors
dans notre système solaire on a plein
d'exemples à de différents objets c'est
très très riches notre système et on
peut commencer à réfléchir un petit peu
aux critères d'habitabilité de nos
planètes
on a les planètes géantes comme jupiter
qui sont tellement massive avec une
atmosphère très dense que il suffirait
qu'on aille un petit peu à travers les
couches de l'atmosphère pour être
complètement écrasés par la pression
avant d'atteindre une hypothétique
surface sur laquelle on pourrait se
tenir debout
la lune beaucoup plus petit a pas été
capable de garder son atmosphère au
moment de sa création
l'atmosphère s'est simplement évaporée
la terre est un peu plus massive a été
capable de conserver une atmosphère qui
nous protège de tout un tas de trucs et
puis nous permet de respirer
l'autre critère c'est aussi la distance
par rapport qui sépare la planète de
l'étoile encore une fois on a un exemple
de notre système on à la terre on est
contentes qu'elles soient habitables
encore mais on a aussi d'autres exemples
qui sont un peu plus près ces venus un
peu plus loin c'est mars et on voit bien
l'effet que ça à d'être plus proche il
fait certainement plus chaud et sur
vénus on a eu un effet de serre qui a
été fortement accéléré à de façon
complètement naturel sur le coup et qui
rend la planète complètement invivable
mars un peu plus lointaine moins
ensoleillées beaucoup plus froides
on commence à trouver les traces d'eau
liquide vous en entendrez parler ces
jours ci à la télé mais c'est vraiment
très très ténue ça n'a rien à voir avec
notre planète à nous et donc on a trouvé
tellement d'objets maintenant qu'on est
capable de 1,2 dont on connaît les
tailles dont on connaît les masses et
donc on est capable de gros quantifier
la halle à la ressemblance que ce
monde-là peuvent avoir à la terre
l'envié des gens qui sont amusés à
bricoler une espèce d'un indice qui donc
si on arrive à trouver une copie
parfaite de la terre voudrait exactement
1 pour cette planète et est donc pour
avoir un peu des références mars par
exemple vu ce système de calcul à aurait
un indice de 0 64 ça veut dire qu'il est
64% proche de la terre jupiter est très
très loin times que 12% ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on a trouvé vous
voyez tout un paquet d'objets kepler 338
438 b 296e etc etc qui sont beaucoup
plus semblables à notre planète a priori
que ne l'est mars puisque plutôt
chouette parce que mars c'est notre
prochaine destination naturelle en tant
qu'humain dans l'espace alors l'étape
d'après maintenant qu'est ce que c'est
c'est de savoir si est-ce qu'on comment
est-ce qu'on va aller chercher des
traces qui vont nous permettre de dire
si il ya de la vie sur cette planète là
et si elle est potentiellement habitable
alors ce qu'on fait dans ces cas là
c'est qu'on voudrait utiliser une
technique qu'on appelle la spectroscopie
on va prendre la lumière de tous ces
objets là et la décomposer un peu
comme le fait un arc en ciel quand il ya
la pluie les bonnes conditions de
luminosité et on va donc décomposer les
différentes composantes de la lumière en
couleur et si on regarde de très près en
arc en ciel on peut se rendre compte
qu'à des endroits très précis il manque
des couleurs on a une espèce de
code-barres qu'apparaît et le
code-barres il est caractéristique de la
présence des éléments chimiques qui
composent l'objet en question
c'est comme ça qu'on est capable de
savoir que dans le soleil il ya des
métaux il ya de l'hélium et l'hydrogène
et tout ça donc les gens sont amusés à
faire ce genre d'observation la r1
comparer ce qu'un observateurs externes
observerait en comparant de mars vénus
et la terre encore une fois et on voit
qu'ils qu'on serait a priori capable de
dire en observant dans certaines bandes
de fréquences ou de longueur d'onde
autour de 10 microns dans l'infrarouge
autour d'eux en gros dans le rouge dans
le visible on serait capable de détecter
la présence d'oxygène gazeux celui qu'on
respire qui nous fait respirer ou
d'ozone
en pratique on n'a pas encore réussi à
faire ça et la raison pour laquelle on
n'a pas réussi a encore dû faire ce
parce que c'est super dur à faire pour
vous donner un petit peu une idée de la
difficulté à je voudrais vous montrer
cette image là qui est absolument génial
c'est une vue du système solaire par la
sonde cassini et on a choisi le bon
moment où cassini est passé entre le
soleil il ya eu saturn qui cachait le
soleil et qui du coup nous permettent de
voir un petit peu ce qui se passe autour
de saturne et à vous êtes tous sur cette
photo c'est une espèce de celle fit un
dans la photo on est là vous êtes tous
là dans cette photo là ce que carl sagan
appeler un petit point bleu pâle en gros
c'est à ça que se résume la terre vue
depuis saturne
il ya un autre vaisseau 40 pris une
photo un peu comparable et qui est un
peu plus ancienne et mais qui encore
plus lointaine qui a été prise par le
voyageur un qui est vraiment à la limite
du système solaire on a encore une fois
parce que le petit point bleu pâle mais
alors là aussi on voit que ben on a le
soleil qui domine tout dans cette
histoire là
les planètes sont imperceptibles pour
espérer capter un petit peu de leur
lumière on est obligé d'avoir des
télescopes qui deviennent de plus en
plus grands l'autre problème c'est que
le soleil il est typiquement entre 1 et
10 milliards de fois plus brillant et
donc si on n'y fait rien on ne voit que
le soleil quand on regarde les systèmes
faller et l'autre problème c'est que les
étoiles
elles sont typiquement entre 100 et 200
mille fois plus loin que la distance que
vous avez là sur cette image ce qui veut
dire que le soleil et la terre ils sont
en gros les uns sur les autres en moins
mon travail c'est de construire et de
réfléchir aux moyens de malgré tout les
voir et donc on s'inspire d'une idée qui
date des années 30 qui était inventée
par quelqu'un qui s'appelait bernard
alliot qui s'inspirait lui-même du
phénomène des éclipses et donc on a
essayé de reconstruire une éclipse en
boîte
en gros c'est quelque chose qu'on
appelle un coronographe parce qu'à
l'époque sa cervelle observer la
couronne du solaire et on l'adapté au
cas des étoiles il ya beaucoup plus de
technologie maintenant là dedans
et la bonne nouvelle c'est que ça
commence à marcher genre de choses et je
vous montre ici quelques images que vous
avez peut-être vu à deux systèmes
planétaires qui datent seulement il ya
quelques années le plus célèbre
c'est celui là hr 87 99 qui est un
système à quatre planètes et plus
récemment 51 eridani encore 51 une
coïncidence qui est un système sur
lequel on a trouvé à une seule planète
pour le moment ce qui est particulier
dans ce système là c'est que ce sont
encore une fois des bizarreries des
choses qui sont pas du tout à comme
notre système solaire à nous
la raison pour laquelle on a réussi à
directement image et ses planètes là
c'est qu'elles sont extrêmement
brillante en fait comparer à notre
système solaire qui est très très mature
4,5 milliards d'années quand même le
respect ces systèmes là sont des bébés
de 20 millions d'années seulement
et donc les planètes qui en gros sortent
de leurs couveuses littéralement sont
encore très très chaude et rayonne
énormément
hors énergie ce qui fait qu'on arrive à
les voir beaucoup plus facilement donc
l'étape d'après ça va vraiment être de
faire le même genre de choses sur des
étoiles matures un peu comme notre
soleil pour essayer d'aller chercher des
planètes sur lesquelles on pourrait
espérer mutuellement trouver la vie je
vous ai dit qu'on est en train de
s'équiper des moyens qui vont nous
permettra de faire ce genre de choses là
on veut des grands télescopes et donc à
on est en train en europe de s'équiper
d'un système qui va devrait arriver dans
d'ici une dizaine d'années c'est un
télescope avec un miroir de 39 mètres de
diamètre on aura suffisamment de
résolution angulaire avec intel
télescope pour être capable de
directement voir les planètes
telluriques comme ça les planètes
rocheuses autour des étoiles un petit
peu plus froide que le soleil on a des
raisons pour ça parce qu'on aura besoin
de les observer dans l'infrarouge pour
aller chercher les planètes autour des
étoiles de type solaire
on sera obligé d'aller dans l'espace et
d'aller observer non pas dans
l'infrarouge mais dans le visible et
c'est beaucoup plus facile d'observer
dans le visible depuis l'espace
mais ce que j'ai envie de vous dire
c'est que j'espère que toutes ces
découvertes là de nouvelles planètes ne
vont pas se traduire que par des
connaissances abstraite où on sera
capable d'aller consulter une base de
données sur laquelle on sera capable de
dire ah oui à la planète
kepler 486 b qui a un indice de temps
c'est super ce que j'ai envie de vous
dire c'est plutôt que c'est très facile
de d'aller vous réapproprier le ciel de
sortir de prendre le temps encore une
fois de vous perdre dans les étoiles
dans l'immensité et d'utiliser le ciel
pour vous réapproprier tout ces planètes
parce que vous pouvez peut-être pas les
voir directement mais vous pouvez dans
la majorité voire tous les soleils de
ces planètes là et profitez-en pour
rêver à ce que ces planètes peuvent vous
inspirez merci